order the following Pizza for the task
master without using any of the
following words extra large pizza with
pepperoni peppers pepper pineapple tuna
and deal most accurate Pizza order and
vocabulary winds also you get an extra
point if you can make the pizza person
say the wide bubbles oh my god hold on
it's Lisa how are you how are you doing
wonderful that's one infected if I could
place an order afternoon how are you
doing wonderfully yeah nice nice day
beautiful by then it's the perfect time
for you know ordering what you need
yeah man listen to me you know the round
things you sell they're made out of
dough and sauce and cheese we ever call
somebody to think only thought the flat
bang that's the biggest size you have
extra lunch okay I'll do that what's the
biggest you have large no it's not can
you make mine a little bit more big I'd
like a very big one please what guy the
biggest hello
and then just wait and why's the I want
I'm sorry I don't order that many pizzas
what kind of pizza toppings do you have
well I thought I think we've got cut off
can i order the pizza is that all right
tomato green pepper I think that what's
the first one if you run through them
I'll just say yes yes yes okay go hello
could I have a Hawaiian one without
behinds what would you put in instead of
ham what do you want a very something
very I'm sorry I've just forgotten the I
don't even answer now they like blow me
off just one last question do any fruit
that you put on top type of fruit no
just sprinkle on a little bit of salt
and and thingy the way salt and and it's
pressed okay yes give me 100
jimin's take that to the shop go thank
you sir
me
[Applause]